in parks
on the tube
even in private at home
nitrous oxide is a common party drug but
it can also be big business
just ask Matt crazy's mom crazy you
could sell it on eBay Gumtree insta
everywhere the demand was nuts and I
think the scary point for me was when
you saw little kids doing it it became a
bit of a craze it was literally
everywhere all the time
and that's the problem according to the
body which advice
for its XPS
truly fingers it comes as hospitals
across the country reported a spike in
nitrous oxide related admissions how
much
okay just one the council decided that
the gas isn't harmful enough to Warrant
a ban instead it suggests the illegal
sale of it must be tackled
it's welcomed news for those who dislike
the idea of criminalizing drug use
Professor David Nutt is a known advocate
for decriminalizing drugs it actually
points out that the harmful effects of
nitrous oxide aren't as harmful as
people make out and they do not warrant
criminalizing people because
criminalizing them would actually be
considerably more harmful to their lives
than they're actually taking nitrous
oxide so I think it's a sensible
approach among the other recommendations
is that local authorities and police
should have more Powers one of the ways
to do that is through a public spaces
protection order like they have here in
Tower hamlets it makes antisocial
Behavior associated with the use of
nitrous oxide and offense and when it
was launched in 2021 it was hugely
popular
a pspo only covers public spaces and a
local councilor has told us it doesn't
go far enough we need to have some sort
of tougher legislation which allows our
police officer obviously to go and
obviously issue some sort of uh you know
this prosecute somebody who is not doing
not using it in appropriate manner
without that businesses are left to ask
the questions this seller who wanted to
speak to us anonymously told us he only
sells nitrous oxide for catering use I
asked them what are they intending to
use our cream chargers for
if they say
for catering purposes then yeah we can
go along once it's in the person's hands
I don't know what's what they get they
could do whatever they want with them
the home office said it's working to
crack down on drug misuse and will now
consider the advice Sadia Chaudhary Sky
News